[Applaus]
stock berlin ist auf gefällt unter dem
araber klangs prostitution waffenhandel
geldwäsche
schutzgeld menschenhandel jeder hat sein
territorium raubtier wird eine
erpressung aufschrift ohne geld läuft
gar nichts man kann sich sozusagen ein
staat im staate aufbauen haben sie angst
vor der familie geschah hat die
deutschen gesetze interessieren ich
möchte nichts dazu sagen und die
deutschen lebensregel auch nichts gehört
eigentlich zum prestige dazu dass man
ins gefängnis geht dann bis man auch die
größeren nummer die jeweiligen
familienoberhäupter tauschen sich aus
wer ist der stärkere wer hat mehr gewalt
wenn es jetzt ärger gab dann ist man
damit 30 mann aufgetaucht in berlin ist
ein mann auf offener straße erschossen
worden wir sind uns der gefahr bewusst
dass der streit zwischen bushido und
seinem ehemaligen management eskaliert
77 grundstücke sind weil 12 durchsuchen
vorläufig sichergestellt worden die
organisierte kriminalität ist eingezogen
die polizei ist machtlos gegen diese
clans wir sind hoffnungslos verloren
[Musik]